- [Voiceover] So we have some words here
that relate the different reactions
and whether they absorb or release
different types of energy.
So the first word here, exothermic.
Exothermic the root of the word is therm
which relates to heat
and these word indeed
means a reaction that releases heat.
Releases, it releases heat.
And one way to think about
it if you're thinking about
constant pressures or change in enthalpy
it can be viewed as your,
how much heat you absorb or release.
So a negative change in enthalpy
means that you're releasing heat.
One way to think of, if you
view enthalpy as heat content
you have less heat content
after the reaction than before
it was meant you release heat.
Which means you're change
in enthalpy is going to be
less than zero so these
all mean the same thing.
Well, this is true.
You're releasing heat.
This is a same thing as
releasing heat if you talk about
constant pressure.
Constant pressure which is a reasonable
assumption if you're doing
something in a beaker
that's open to the air
or if you're thinking
about a lot of different
biological systems.
Now based on that logic what
do you think this word means,
endothermic.
Well endothermic, therm
same root and now your prefix is endo
so this is a process that absorbs heat.
Absorbs heat.
Or if you're thinking
of a constant pressure,
you can say your enthalpy
after the reaction
is gonna be higher than the
enthalpy before the reaction.
So your delta H is going to be
greater than zero.
All right, fair enough.
Now let's look at these
two characters over here.
Exergonic and endergonic
so exergonic the root here is ergon
and you might not be as familiar with that
as you are with therm
but you might have heard
the word ergonomic.
Say, hey that's a nice ergonomic desk.
That means it's a desk
that's good to do work at
or it's a nice ergonomic chair.
An ergon does indeed come
from the Greek for work.
And so exergonic is a reaction
that releases work energy
or at least that's what the word implies.
Releases, let me do
that in the same color.
This is something that is going to
release work
energy.
And endergonic, same logic,
well that's gonna be
something based on just
the way the word is setup
that absorbs work energy
or uses work
energy.
Now one of our variables
or properties that we can
use to think about energy
that can be used for
work is Gibbs free energy
and the formula for Gibbs free energy,
if we're thinking about constant
pressure and temperature,
so let me write that down.
So if we're talking
about constant pressure
and temperature then the formula
for Gibbs free energy or
you can even view this
as a definition of Gibbs free energy.
The change in Gibbs free energy,
let me do this in another color.
The change in Gibbs
free energy is equal to
our change in enthalpy
minus, use in the different color.
Minus our temperature
times our change in entropy
and if this looks
completely foreign to you,
I encourage you to watch the video
on Gibbs free energy but the reason why
this is related to energy for work
is okay, look I have my,
whether I'm absorbing
or I'm releasing heat
and I'm subtracting out entropy
which is kind of the energy
that is going to the
disorder of the universe
and what's left over is the
energy that I can do for work.
That's one way to think about it.
So you can see that
this relates work energy
to change in enthalpy right over here.
So exergonic, something that releases
work energy could say
that has less work energy
after the reaction than before it,
your delta G is going
to be less than zero.
So let me write that down.
So here our delta G is
going to be less than zero
and these things, these
are reactions that release
work energy, we've seen it
in the video on Gibss free energy.
We consider this to be spontaneous.
Spontaneous.
These are going to move forward.
So these over here, the ones
that absorb work energy,
well they're gonna have more work energy
in the system than before is
one way to think about it.
So your delta G
is going to be greater than zero
and we say these are not spontaneous.
So these are not spontaneous.
Now that we have the
definitions out of the way
and we have a way to
relate these variables,
let's look at these
different scenarios of things
that are exothermic and exergonic
or exothermic and endergonic and see why
they make an intuitive sense.
So in this first reaction
it's exothermic, our delta H
is less than zero.
That means it has less
enthalpy after the reaction
than before which means it released heat
and so you can see here,
this heat is being released.
And where did that energy come from?
Well when it bonds
in this new configurations on a net basis
the electrons are able to
go to lower energy states
and release that energy.
And heat, if you're thinking
about in a microscopic scale
it's something that's
raising your temperature
at least locally which it
means just about transferring
kinetic energy to these
microscopic molecules.
Remember when you're talking
about heat or temperature
you're thinking about
these macro variables
but on a microscopic variable,
you're talking about kinetic
energies and potential energies
and things like that.
So what's happening is these electrons
or when they get into a new configuration
and they're going to release energy
and that can be transferred
to the individual molecules.
So you see here, we've released energy
and we also have an increase in entropy.
We have more entropy after the reaction
than before the reaction.
We have more objects right over here,
there's more states in which
they could actually be in
and they're actually moving faster.
So this one, we see if you just apply,
if you apply the formula over here
this is gonna be less than zero.
This over here, delta S is
going to be greater than zero.
The temperature, that's
gonna be absolute temperature
in terms of Kelvin so it's
always going to be positive
and so this whole term
is going to be positive
so you're gonna have a
negative, minus a positive
it's going to be negative.
So our delta G
is going to be less than zero and we see
that this is spontaneous.
This is going to move
forward and it makes sense,
it releases energy, the electrons like it.
It creates a more disordered state.
Another way to think
about it is think about
trying to do the reaction the other way,
you're gonna have to get some
energy for those electrons
to get into a higher
energy state when they form
these new bonds your gonna have to get
these four constituents
together in the exact right way.
That seems a lot less likely to happen
than going in from the left to the right.
Now let's think about
something that absorbs heat
and this one's a little
bit counter intuitive.
It absorbs heat but it's
still going to be spontaneous.
It's still going to be exergonic.
It's still going to happen.
So delta H is greater than zero
so it absorbs heat to happen.
So I have these two molecules
with these different constituents,
they are about to collide
and we're saying that
the temperature is high.
If the temperature is low,
this might not be spontaneous
but if the temperature is
high enough it will be.
So the temperature high
in a microscopic basis,
you're saying, okay these
things just have them,
really high kinetic energy,
they're going to ram into
each other really fast
and they're gonna ram
into each other so fast
that they can form all
these other constituents.
So you have the net entropy,
you have the net entropy has increased.
Even though over here our electrons
are in a higher energy state
to form this configuration
so it had to absorb heat,
so it had to absorb heat energy.
So we could say heat but
heat on a microscopic level,
we're just talking about
kind of kinetic energy
of these molecules.
So it have to absorb it but
where did that energy come from?
Well, it came from the kinetic
energy of the molecules.
They might had a certain
kinetic energy before
but then some of that gets lost
so when they all get banged up
into their different configurations.
If you're saying, well
I still don't get this.
Think about trying to do
this reaction the other way.
Try to get these four
constituents in the right time,
all together, even though
if they're happening,
if they're put together at the right way
their electrons could configure
in a way to release energy
but this is super high temperature.
This is a really, really chaotic system.
It's not gonna go from right to left,
it's gonna go from left to right.
When it's really chaotic,
things are banging
each other really fast,
you're more likely to go
on a direction of higher entropy.
So now let's look at,
and so this is spontaneous
even though it absorbs heat.
If you're not draining
the heat away locally,
your temperature at least
around these molecules
it will go down.
But as source we're assuming
constant temperature
for this so you can assume
that in a macro level
that temperature dissipates
and gets absorbed
outside of the system somehow.
Now, let's look at this configuration.
It's exothermic so delta
H is less than zero,
less enthalpy after the
reaction than before
so it's releasing heat
but it's not spontaneous.
And it's not spontaneous
because it's reducing
the entropy in the world.
It's reducing the entropy in the world
and the entropy matters because
our temperature is high.
One way to look at this equation
is entropy doesn't matter
when temperature is low.
Temperature is really scaling your entropy
but when temperature is high,
entropy start to take over.
This variable starts to matter a lot.
So over here, because entropy is negative,
this isn't gonna, this thing's
not gonna actually happen.
So if these things were
coming together very slowly,
their electrons could
configure in just the right way
so that they can get
to a lower energy state
and release energy.
But they're buzzing
pass each other so fast
that they're not gonna
have a chance to do that.
If you think about it the
other way, this reaction
is much more likely to happen.
If you have a bunch of
this diatomic molecules
running around, they're gonna
bump into each other so fast
that they're gonna knock
the constituents off of
these diatomic molecules or at
least the way it's depicted,
it kinda looks like a diatomic molecule.
And they might absorb some
of that kinetic energy
in doing it, in order
to go from right to left
but that's more likely to happen.
So from left to right not spontaneous
because entropy really matters
at this high temperature.
Then finally, and this
one's pretty intuitive
something that needs heat,
something that needs heat energy
and has a reduction in entropy
that's definitely not
going to be spontaneous.
So this is greater than
zero, this is less than zero
but then you're subtracting
it so this whole thing
is greater than zero, this delta G
is going to be greater than zero.
Delta, let me do that in a green color.
This delta G is going
to be greater than zero
and it makes sense that you
have these two molecules
that you have to get together
in just the right way.
They need heat in order to
proceed with this reaction
to kind of excite, to excite the electrons
to higher energy state to get into this,
I guess you could say less stable bond.
Why would they do that?
The reaction is much more
likely to go in this way
or if you had a bunch of these molecules
they're all knocking into each other,
they get into a more stable configuration
and there's more entropy
when they split up
than when they actually stay together.
So delta G greater than zero.
This is endergonic and endothermic
and of course, this one was
delta G greater than zero.
Even though this would release energy
that the things that's so
chaotic they're not gonna have
a chance to do that and
you're much more likely to go
in the direction of maximizing entropy
and so this one also is not spontaneous.